Smoky enough for you well the big story
this week was the haze my God the haze
it was in New York it was in
Philadelphia it was in Washington DC and
all the surrounding areas well never
mind the fact that this happened out
west well and no one cared about it
right well our increased Wildfire is a
real Mark of climate change or more
importantly or wildfires actually even
increasing well the green New Deals High
Priestess of course she seems to think
so earlier this week AOC accused the 24
hours of smog and high temperatures in
Puerto Rico it's hot in June in Puerto
Rico did you know that
to push her policy prescriptions it
Bears repeating how unprepared we are
for the climate crisis we must adapt Our
Food Systems energy grids infrastructure
Health Care Etc ASAP to prepare for
what's to come and catch up to what is
already here
but famed meteorologist Anthony Watts
says she's wrong on both counts he's
here now to explain why Anthony great to
see you tonight
um first on the insistence
and you this drum beat has continued now
for quite some time that wildfires are
increasing the numbers of wildfires is
that actually the case
well no and in fact there was a huge
Wildfire event in Canada on May 19 1789
that caused the entire New England area
to dark out so much that people had to
light candles to see during midday and
it was called New England's dark day so
this kind of event has happened before
but more importantly than that we've had
wildfires in the United States that were
worse far worse back in the 1920s and
30s and the data supports it the data
shows that wildfires covered much more
acreage way back then than they do today
now Anthony I want you to hear what um
the Canadian Prime Minister pretty boy
Justin Trudeau said earlier in the week
year after year with climate change
we're seeing more and more intense
wildfires and in places where they don't
normally happen that's why we've
invested to train more community-based
firefighters across the country
well as it turns out wildfires in Canada
are quite normal so normal the Canada's
Government website has a page Anthony
devoted to educating the public about
them and this one says that why forests
need fires so they actually concede that
and that's correct so what is this
really all about all this Hysteria
well you know what's happened lately is
that the left has started to blame
virtually every weather or abnormal
event on climate change it's sort of
become the universal Boogeyman of blame
I mean something changes that's abnormal
well it must be climate change they
don't really think this through they
don't go back and look at data they
don't go back and look at history to see
if this has happened before they don't
look for the causes and things and so
that's the problem they're out there
spewing rhetoric and it really boils
down to this who do you want to believe
you want to believe a bartender turned
politician with an agenda or solid data
that says there's no climate crisis
while I choose data every day of the
week and twice on Sunday now this other
very important story
um is your contention that temperature
measurement stations that are that are
strategically placed to promote in your
view the most radical climate priorities
if you could explain that for us I'd
really appreciate it tonight
well it's really pretty simple NOAA the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
administrations in charge of weather
stations all across the United States
for a measuring temperature used in
climate studies the problem is they're
not maintaining them properly and my
studies going and visiting hundreds and
hundreds of these stations around the
United States shows that they're
improperly cited NOAA has a simple rule
about the placement of these stations
compared to where they're supposed to be
they're supposed to be in pristine areas
like in a field somewhere but what we
actually have found is that they're in
parking lots we have found that they're
next to brick walls we've found that
they're next to exhaust vents for air
conditioners all sorts of things and in
fact my study last year following up
from one I did in 2009 shows the problem
getting worse
96 percent of the weather stations in
the United States used to measure
climate by the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration are
compromised and these compromised
stations actually read warmer than the
stations that are still in pristine that
are out in the fields that are away from
all the infrastructure of humanity thank
you for doing this and great to see you
as always
my pleasure hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else